the difference between someone playing
hard to get and flirting or is it not
being interested so number one I think
touching is a big thing so for example
like if I flirt I'm gonna probably at
some point touch a guy if I have a
conversation with a guy where I'm
laughing a couple of times and with back
and forth thing that's just a
conversation I think that's on you
though for like the guys you pick
well I picked the wrong guy yeah I did I
did but but not overall it's just the
men that I've seen all have the same
thing I I'm not I'm not picking because
I I don't really have that problem like
I mean like where it's every time I date
someone and I'm a very like I talk for a
living you know what I mean and I've
just never really had that problem where
men in general are stupid jealous so it
just seems like that's like an issue
with either your ability to pick or
maybe something you're doing but you
have to